this movie taught me one important thing
I really need to go to Vegas again
[Music]
Molly's gay so Molly's game is written
and directed by Aaron Sorkin who usually
writes the scripts that others direct
he's written social network Steve Jobs
the newsroom the West Wing but he wrote
Molly's game and this is his directorial
debut as far as I know and Molly's game
starts Jessica Chastain who plays Molly
who is a poker princess or queen
don't call her princess she helped out
with her colleagues underground poker
night such a pretty high stack so she
was like I could do that so she did that
in the beginning of the movie the FBI
has busted into her house and seized
dollars [ __ ] so this is her talking with
her lawyer played by Idris Elba also
showing the story as it leads up to that
I really enjoyed this I really enjoy
Aaron Sorkin's writing and that's what
you see from here if you didn't know it
was directed by Aaron Sorkin you would
know it was written by a man Aaron
Sorkin script is an easy thing to spot
just everyone has that quippy dialogue
everyone talks like Aaron Sorkin's brain
but damn it if I don't find that
entertaining so that's the hook for me
but also Jessica Chastain I cannot pick
out a role of Jessica Chastain roles
like and she kind of phoned it in she
wasn't that right Jessica Chastain is
awesome and she's great in here you
really feel for her story from the
beginning the beginning set up for her
is humorous it looks almost irrelevant
but it's not irrelevant and from there
she's working for a scumbag and you're
like I want you to succeed in all of
this where this movie really hits home
for me is not only do I enjoy poker but
I like the entrepreneurialship of all of
it I like seeing someone start something
from nothing or at least the ground
level which wasn't really nothing when
it started in the first place but she
just builds it I love it I love it when
a movie can illustrate the business
element of something is something that
is complicated and then break it down
for the crowds like this is why this is
important hey he this is why he's
betting like this because this is the
hand he has movie does a good job but
even if you don't play poker
you'll probably get what's going on in
the poker scheme of things the movie
does bounce around between timelines so
sometimes you're like wait are we there
are we there's a couple times I felt
like I could have gone for something an
indicator that we're now no longer there
we're now talking about what happened
before doesn't happen often just a
couple times I was like wait where are
we right now so it's a little jarring
until you get the structure down and the
biggest fault this movie has is this
illustration and time passing this
movie's actually surprisingly long and
though a couple times I was like all
right it can end now I felt like it
could have been longer if it could
illustrate the passage of time I sent
weren't thing in a movie like this
supposedly she was doing this poker gig
for years it's an important thing to
illustrate passage of time in a movie
dealing with chronology of events at a
point like all right it's been what a
week it couldn't have been a week
because she's been at this for a couple
years as movie spans years when it feels
like it spans a couple months I could be
problematic also when she starts getting
her pill addiction you're like I guess
she's hooked on pills I'd never really
illustrates that she's off her game
until later on she says she was off her
game I didn't know there was nothing
about it that screamed addict to me it
would've been weren't interesting for me
if they had played that angle in somehow
seeing her slowly be like I'm not on my
a game anymore rather than in the
segment that takes place later on when
she's talking with the lawyers they were
like this happened she's like yeah I was
off my game guys in the end Molly's game
was actually quite damn entertaining the
poker element intrigued me the
entrepreneurialship intrigued me I was
interested in Molly story and I was
actually rooting for her to succeed
because unlike a lot of other stories
like this she's actually not a piece of
[ __ ] and jessica chastain straight-up
hits at home she's a goddess among us
all hello say Molly's game is definitely
a great time no alcohol required booze
drugs alcohol gambling happy holidays
all right guys so Molly's game have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]